[Music]
everybody welcome to protect Costa
College today I just want to make this
tutorial for those people who are
struggling with coastal building and
parka texts or who just picked up the
game and are wondering about how the
coaster editor works so this will be a
basic introduction to how to use the
track builder in parka texts to build
coasters still I think if your
experience with the game and you know
how to build coasters there might be
some interesting tips and tricks
throughout this video as well is that
something that I want to mention as well
and also I need to express my debts that
I have to max freak who made an earlier
tutorial on the coaster builder and
which was a really good video and one of
the reasons that I was afraid to get
into this but I think that with the
recent addition of the autocomplete
feature the his tutorial has become a
little bit outdated so that's why I like
to make this video as well and focus
especially on how autocomplete works and
also I'll be doing a few things outside
of just showing how the coaster editor
works so I also want to show some
layouts for instance that I've built to
point out some tips and tricks and stuff
like that now without further ado let's
get into it and I'll explain everything
along the way so if we want to build a
coaster obviously we need to go to the
right section and build a coaster I'm
just gonna pick the floorless coaster
for now but the type doesn't really
matter I'm not going to focus in this
video on how to build realistic coasters
of specific types or how to get certain
excitement ratings etc I just want to
focus on how to use the Builder itself
so for the station I always like that to
be raised off the ground
max free-cos also said that this is just
going to make it easier to get back to
the station at the end of the ride but
it's also very much a realism thing
real-life coasters tend to have their
stations raised a little bit and in
scenarios and stuff like that you can
even put some key lines or exit paths
stuff like that underneath the station
as well so that's always handy now here
is the track builder itself and
the real meat of this tutorial so when I
first saw this I noticed that it looks
very similar to coaster builders from
other theme park related games mostly
roller coaster tycoon because that's my
main experience in the genre but there
are some really big differences and I
think the most crucial difference is
that the sort of traditional coaster
builder that works piece by piece like
this uses the UI to let you choose a
number of prefabricated track pieces so
for instance straight to gentle slope
pieces and gentle to steep slope pieces
things like that but this UI even though
it looks very similar
you use it to choose what you want a
track piece to be like before you build
it and it gives you a lot of flexibility
in terms of what you do with it you can
choose the slope you can choose the
curve and you can choose the banking and
with all of these three combined you
have pretty much limitless options as
far as what you can do on a grid because
in the end at the end of the day the
game is still based on a grid so that is
a limiting thing but aside from that as
long as everything sticks on the grid
you can come up with pretty much
anything you want something to also note
is obviously we see some numbers here
with four and four and a half these are
the the height styles that you use to
basically calculate what every slope is
going to be like so for instance if I
keep going straight we end up at four
here is the quarter slope up where after
two grid tiles we end up at four and a
quarter here's the half slope up where
we end up at four and a half and here's
the full slope up where we end up at
five and all of these scale accordingly
as well so if we take the quarter for
instance and make the track piece one
grid tile longer we end up at four
three-eighths and another great tile
ends up at four and a half whereas if we
take the half slope up if we increase
that by just one tile we end up at four
three quarters and one more tile we end
up
it's five etc and this girls up all the
way that set the fourth slope up is I
guess in number a little bit different
soon as you can see it goes from five to
seven here and by the time he gets a
four slope up every single grid space is
an entire well number in terms of
heights so you can see we go from ten to
eleven to twelve etc and then at the end
there is vertical which makes your track
go vertical as the name suggests
so with these all together it used to be
quite finicky because you had to get
back into the station without an
autocomplete feature so these numbers
used to be extremely important to get
back to the exact same height of this
station but nowadays that's not really
true anymore since we have the
autocomplete feature so I would say
don't be too worried about the numbers
you can usually find your way back to
the station Heights at the end of the
ride by Auto completing it as long as
you get close enough but you can still
use it as a general guide of knowing you
know how high your track piece is going
to be but we will get into that later
I'll show you how that sort of comes
into play for now I just want to build a
lift Hill which typically is about
thirty degrees so I'm gonna go about a
half slope up which is basically well
technically it's about 25% it should be
since we are moving at two grid tiles
and we're moving half a space up but
yeah I'm just gonna build the lift or
like that and as I'm building I'm also
gonna increase the length of the track
pieces makes it a little bit quicker but
also means that we don't have too many
supports here and at this point I think
we're pretty safe to end the lift hill
here so I'm just gonna go straight again
and remove the lifts option here and now
it's time for some drops now something
which I think is worth to point out is
if you're used to these older piece by
piece builders you would have to sort of
do things in steps so you would first
have to go to a gentle slope and then a
slightly steeper slope and then an even
steeper slope if you wanted to get to
the steep slopes I think that's not only
unnecessary in part X but it also makes
the coaster a little bit less smooth and
this
becomes especially apparent if you don't
if you skip any in-between slopes if we
go from this slope to this one for
instance you can see it becomes very
unfair and that's something that we
don't really want so you can go from
straights to any kind of slope instantly
so I would just generally recommend to
do that instead so in this case I'm
gonna go straight from well straights to
a steep slope for the first drop and I
think I'm just gonna end up at four
usually I don't like to let my tracks
touch the ground you can obviously do
this but out of realism purposes I'm
gonna keep them raised a little bit
because in real life coasters are
usually never touching the ground
because they always need to be supported
by some kind of support so I'm just
gonna go straight here and I think it's
time for our first elements just as a
word of caution I want to say that I'm
not trying to build a realistic coaster
layout here I just want to try and build
as many elements as I can to show you
how to make different kinds of elements
and how I like to make different kinds
of elements but the final layout is
probably going to be a little bit weird
now for some elements you can just
choose them out of the menu here so for
instance for a loop for a vertical loop
we can just choose one in the menu here
and scale it according to how big our
coaster is so that's pretty easy and the
same goes for corkscrews for instance we
just have the corkscrews from the menu
here but for other elements you're gonna
want to build them yourself so I'm gonna
start off with a zero zero which is
basically just a hill with a twist in
the middle and actually maybe I'm gonna
build that a little bit taller yeah I
probably should so I'm gonna go back
into a decently steep slope although no
not quite as steep as this one and I
think just have one straight section
here that should be good and as you can
see you also don't have to go straight
before you want to go down again you can
just click going down right away so that
sometimes helps a
a little bit of time but in the case of
a zero zero it makes the role a little
bit smoother because you could make a
role by for instance doing this building
one piece where you start banking upside
down and then building another piece
where you go straight again but as you
can see this is not very smooth so what
I usually like to do is just make it one
long piece like this and just take the
banking and bank it all the way and that
is going to make a twist and let's see
if that makes it with a decent speed and
yeah I'd say that's perfect so let's get
down to the ground again and build
another elements and for this element
I'm thinking of building a cobra roll
because this shows off how the half loop
elements work really well
so the half loop is an elements that
kind of goes straight like this but you
can also choose it to go left like this
or right like this so for a cobra roll
because I want this to be somewhere
around here I'm gonna go left first and
then go into a corkscrew and actually
I'm going to bank the end of this
corkscrew a little bit as well which is
something that you can do for corkscrews
which makes them super flexible you can
bank them in any way you like
so I'm gonna experiment a little bit
more with that later but for now I'm
just going to make the section between
the cork screws a little bit banked
because that's something that real life
Cobra rolls tend to do and it just makes
the inversion little bit smoother I
think and then for the other half loop
I'm gonna have that curve to the left
and there you go that's the cobra roll
now over here I could build a loop but I
think I'm just gonna build a simple
airtime Hill here so just gonna build a
hill like this it's very simple pretty
much the easiest elements to build and
then after that I think I want to add a
mid-course brake run over here now I
need to see if this is actually going to
make it and if so at what speed looks
pretty good so far
and yeah that's perfect all right so
here I want to add a mid-course brake
run as they call it which is something
which in my own playthroughs I rarely do
but I highly recommend that you do this
in your longer coasters because this is
what you need to get multiple trains
onto the coaster because the train
system in park tech does follow real
life so you can only have multiple
trains on a single coaster if you have
block breaks in the middle of the
layouts or near the end of it and I
can't really I mean this is a topic that
I could devote a whole video to but
basically coasters work based on blocks
and you can only have the number of
trains equal to the amount of blocks
that you have on the coaster minus one
and a coaster is divided into blocks
based on stations lift hills and block
brakes anything that can stop a train in
the middle of the ride divides it up
into different blocks so this is for
evacuation purposes if anything happens
to go wrong anywhere you can stop all of
the trains on the blocks so you always
need more blocks or more block breaks
then you have trains just for safety
purposes and this also makes sure that
coaster cars can never crash into each
other because only one train is allowed
on a single block at any given time
that's why we need to add these block
sections as well just to make the coast
of Costa is a bit more efficient and
allow us to add multiple trains on them
so I'm gonna add some lock breaks here
and I like to trim the speed if the next
block is clear which make sure that even
if there's no car on the next block it
still breaks it a little bit which you
don't have to do but I like to do that
just to control the speed a little bit
as you can see it's getting break there
is that yeah you say breaks and if there
happens to be another train on this
block and this block wasn't cleared yet
by the next train this train would be
stopped on these breaks until the next
train would be in the station and then
it would let go of the brakes and go
down here now I'm just gonna go
into the drop here and finish the rest
of the ride off with some other kinds of
little elements that I want to show off
so first maybe we might just want to
build a loop even though we are in quite
at a very good height anymore I think
it's still very doable let me test that
never mind I forgot all about the fact
that we are on a one slope down piece so
if I expand this by one grid piece will
be at three and a half which should be a
good heights to build the loop at and
make sure that we clear it with a decent
speed let's check that and yeah I'm
pretty happy with that so I'm gonna add
another airtime Hill here just because
airtime Hills or fun I can't have too
many of those I guess although actually
I'm gonna make it a little bit smaller
on the top here just like that and wow
that actually goes over the station
quite nicely and then one of the last
things that I want to build is corkscrew
and I think it'll be nice to just build
a regular old corkscrew I'm gonna have
to worry about getting back to the
station because I kind of pre-planned
which elements I wanted to build but not
exactly how the layout would go but I'm
sure that'll be fine so yeah here's our
corkscrew and something else which I
think is really interesting about the
corkscrews like I pointed out earlier
you can change the banking on these
things however you want which is not the
case for half loops you always need to
be at perfectly 180 or zero degrees for
those but for corkscrews you can use
them to build for instance over banks
turns so you can build something like
this get back to zero and you basically
have an over-banked to turn like this or
you can even go back to a straight piece
and go back to zero banking like that
and as you can see you can make what's
almost kind of a single dive just really
interesting elements and just like that
I think kind of thinking outside of the
box and using different curves and
inversion pieces together with the
banking and even the sloped pieces works
really well to come up with anything
that you like
and the same does go for slopes as well
for corkscrews because you can add a
corkscrew after a quarter or a half
slope up so as you can see I can still
build a corkscrew
after this although I can't get back to
a different slope with another corkscrew
after that in any case I think it's
actually probably the best to get into
maybe an over-banked turn over here not
quite sure how that would work out but
I'm sure there must be a way that said
if you have less than 90 degrees banking
then not the other corkscrew that comes
after it the game things that you want
to go up again so that's something to be
aware of if you want to make over banked
curves like this you do need to get 95
or more degrees of banking on the
corkscrew thank you rain that is perfect
for tutorial purposes okay we're back
and I think I might actually want to try
and build a helix here which is the
final elements that I would have liked
to get into this layouts so this is
where curves that go up and down come in
as you can see with curves you can also
change the slope however you want that
said you cannot build the steepest slope
with a curve it will just go straight
like that and also if you go into a
curve while you're also having a sloped
piece as you can see it gets very steep
really quickly so you always have to
take into account that curves will make
you go down quite a bit faster than
straight sloped pieces will so in this
case because I want to build some kind
of helix I'm gonna go back to a piece
like that got it don't know if that's
actually going to work out yeah I think
it does alright and looks pretty weird
but I'll take it and then finally the
s-band pieces are something that you can
very easily use to get from any you know
not quite connecting to the station tile
to tile which directly lines up to the
station like this
and I haven't shown off a lot of the
autocomplete feature yet but I think
that I will have to do that on this
final segment because I want to have a
slight banking over here but then I also
want a smooth piece that hooks back up
to the station and I can do this with
either four tiles of a quarter slope up
as you can see where we get back to four
or two tiles of a half slope up let's
get back to four now obviously in this
case I think that the four tiles of a
quarter slope up looks quite a bit
smoother so I want to go for that but
not just that I think this is a bit of
an awkward transition I think they're
banking over here and a little bit too
abruptly so what you can do as long as
the difference in Heights between two
track pieces is small enough the game
will automatically connect them so as
you can see here this half height isn't
quite enough for the game to
automatically connect these two track
pieces but if I build a quarter slope up
it's automatically going to connect them
like this and we get one smooth track
piece where it goes from a bank to a
straight piece that's half a tile higher
and that just makes the whole piece a
little bit more smooth and really the
only way to build like this is with the
autocomplete feature so even though the
autocomplete feature is originally meant
to just help you get back to the station
without having to worry about the
numbers too much I think this also just
makes for really smooth track pieces and
with a bit of manipulation you can make
some track sections which are otherwise
impossible to make in the game work and
oh actually forgot to get rid of the
banking over here alright let me fix
that get back to zero go back to that
and then hook up the two track pieces in
the end there we go and at the end of
the ride I just want to add some more
block brakes although actually I do have
the mid-course lock breaks so it doesn't
matter too much I should be able to get
to trains like this and an entrance and
an exit that is basically its
for our first coastal layouts and these
are some of the most basic elements to
build and how to build them and for the
rest of this tutorial I just want to go
over some other things to keep in mind
and some potential layouts that you
might be able to learn from so first a
little bit more about the autocomplete
feature as long as the height difference
between the track piece that you're
building and the track piece you want to
connect to is less than a quarter I
believe and regardless of banking or
sloping the game is gonna also connect
them so here for instance I'm gonna
build a two tile straight piece but it's
still going to hook it up to this
difference of 1/8 in height it's not
something to keep in mind and also as
you might have noticed it really doesn't
matter what kind of banking or anything
like that you have so if I make this
piece Bank for instance and I try to
connect it to the station piece here
with a piece that goes up so the piece
doesn't end up straight the game is just
automatically going to figure out how to
best connect these two pieces and we get
this interesting sort of banks to
straights slope transition piece as a
result of that another trick that I
personally like to use is having one
piece that goes from a certain slope up
to a different kind of slope down so as
you might be able to notice we can only
go to a half slope down in one piece if
we are at a half slope up but one way to
circumvent this is to just build a
single piece like this then build
another straight piece and then have a
quarter slope down piece for instance
and if we remove the things in-between
we can have a single piece that goes
from a half slope up to a quarter slope
down anyway I hope that short tutorial
gave you some ideas now for the final
parts of this video I want to go over
some layouts that I made myself just to
show you some of the tricks that I've
used and yeah how to basically make use
of the coaster builder to make smooth
and realistic layouts so for this
coaster for instance I think something
that's really interesting to point out
is the drop that we have over here
basically we are going at the lift hill
from a 1/2 slope up piece to or a half
tile up piece to a full tile down slope
and then from that this curve
transitions to a quarter tile down slope
and then this other curve transitions to
just a straight slope so with that you
get this sort of general pretty smooth
curve that goes from a slope down to a
straight piece and then finally a
diagonal piece into this diagonal lupine
and I think that just works to you know
make the whole coaster seem a little bit
less on grid which for me at least
there's always something that I try to
do as much as possible also at the end
there's another one of these pieces
where as you can see it goes from a
piece at four-and-a-half Heights here to
four well at the same time unban canoe a
single trek piece so that was what I
thought was worth showing off for that
coaster this is an intimate mega lights
which is something that you don't see
too much in the game but I think it's
decently possible and it uses the
corkscrew piece actually this is believe
it or not a corkscrew piece to create
this very large over-banked curve here
and then another corkscrew piece over
here to create this small over-banked
curve and then the rest of the ride is
just very simple some airtime Hills just
to end the right because these coasters
tend to be very focused on airtime
whereas these inverted coasters tend to
really just focus on getting many
inversions and then finally here's a
flying coaster which I think work
especially well with this coaster
builder because flying coasters tend to
have a flying segments where you're
underneath the track and lying segments
where you're above the track so here at
the bottom of this pretzel loop there's
a there's a lying track and you pretty
much get all the creativity that you
want in terms of the banking so most of
these elements are quite simple here's
another zero-g roll for instance
here's a piece that uses a curve this is
actually a curve that goes from steep to
straights to create a dive loop but also
here the track is straight for a section
and then it just has a 180 twist to go
from a lying position to a flying
position so that's something that works
really well with this coaster builder in
particular I think because these flying
coasters tend to have really interesting
elements where they just go from a lying
position to a flying position so lots of
creativity is possible there and this is
also another corkscrew I believe now
this is actually not a collector this is
just a curve that goes into a single
track section here where it goes from
flying to line so yeah lots of
interesting possibilities especially
with how you can use banking to kind of
repurpose elements I think anyway that's
it for this tutorial I hope you learned
something from this or it got some ideas
for your own coasters and if you have
any requests or questions feel free to
leave them in the comment section I do
have to say very honestly I don't think
I'll make more tutorials on coasters and
pike texts because it's quite simple
really and I'm already doing a series in
planet coaster on how to make specific
kinds of roller coasters and even though
the coaster builder is very different I
think the overall design philosophy of
the coaster types just carries over into
this game because all of the coasters
are built on real-life counterparts
anyway that's it for this video and I
hope to see you guys in the next parka
tech scenario video maybe bye bye